parlare nel salone per un fiorentino
dovrebbe sembrare normale ma veramente
non lo è è
un'emozione incredibile
e tanto più parlare di cultura
al momento che sono un ingegnere forse è
un po presuntuoso però visto che per
tanti percorsi della vita sono stato
coinvolto con i beni culturali o se
vogliamo una fusione fra arte scienza e
beni culturali
eh sì è vero è questo salone per me
rappresenta qualcosa di più perché già
dal 75 mi ha visto coinvolto nella
ricerca del murale di leonardo da vinci
la battaglia d'anghiari
che si cela sotto queste pitture
vi racconterò un po di qua e un po lo
stato dell'arte su questa ricerca ma
prima permettetemi di fare un po un
excursus
su quello che è lo stato dell'arte si ma
diciamo della scienza che cerca
disperatamente di entrare nel mondo dei
beni culturali per dare una svolta e
certamente un contributo positivo che
potrebbe creare anche molto lavoro è
anche decisamente una valorizzazione dei
nostri beni culturali sia a livello
nazionale ma soprattutto a livello
mondiale visto che
milioni di persone vengano in questo
paese non solo
come visitatori ma anche portarci i
soldi non ce lo scordiamo e forse questi
visitatori si meritano qualcosa di più
almeno quando si interfacciano quando
vedono osservano meravigliati e
affascinate i nostri beni culturali
io penso che oggi se cominciamo a dare
più spazio come ho detto prima ai nostri
beni culturali certamente questo può
portare
un modo migliore per
accattivarci questa loro amicizia questa
loro dedizione al nostro paese e come
vedrete si può fare e si può fare molto
di più
quando noi andiamo in un museo pensiamo
di vedere i capolavori siamo affascinati
però forse dovremmo anche cominciare a
domandarci ma quello che vediamo è tutto
quello che dobbiamo vedere che possiamo
vedere che possiamo apprezzare o
piuttosto
magari c'è ancora così tanto che quegli
artisti ci hanno dato hanno creato ma
noi non riusciamo più né a vederlo né
tantomeno a capirlo
e se riuscissimo invece a vedere il
mistero che si cela dietro la creazione
di ogni capolavoro e se per fare questo
potessimo usare
tecnologia scienza applicata
certamente questo sarebbe per noi un
grande arricchimento ma per tutti coloro
che come ho detto prima ci vengono a
trovare
e ci danno grandi possibilità anche
economiche
c'è un esempio prendiamo uno dei dipinti
più acclamati più conosciuti e prendiamo
leonardo pensiamo di sapere tutto di
leonardo diciamo che siamo appena
all'inizio a capire un po leonardo chi
era soprattutto come artista e non solo
per il mistero della battaglia
d'anghiari
l'adorazione dei magi agli uffizi chi è
che non può che dice può dire di non
averla mai vista
e in effetti io vi dico che non
l'abbiamo mai vista perché solo usando
tecnologie adeguate possiamo riscoprire
anzi scoprire per la prima volta quello
che leonardo veramente ha fatto su
questa su questa opera e cominciamo a
prendere un dettaglio per vederne non
solo più ravvicinato ma se per diciamo
una magia tecnologica potessimo
rimuovere questo questa pittura
monocroma beh forse scopriremo cose che
sono lì ma non abbiamo mai pensato di
poter osservare per esempio la
mangiatoia ma potete vedere che in basso
sulla sinistra si staglia anche la
figura di un elefante che di fatto
leonardo ha dipinto
dipinto anche se un disegno perché in
effetti lo ha fatto a pennello cioè noi
stiamo guardando sotto la superficie
vittoria stiamo guardando il disegno
quello che ci ha lasciato leonardo quel
momento creativo
dalla mente passa alla creazione di
queste figure incredibili oltre 70 che
non abbiamo mai visto in questo dipinto
quello che bisogna fare è usare delle
opportune tecnologie per poter passare
questa pittura
ancora prendiamo un altro dettaglio
incredibile
una raccolta
di ritratti diciamo che sono stati più o
meno
evanescenti per secoli ed ecco che
all'improvviso si rivelano a noi e
vediamo in tutta la sua grandezza
creativa leonardo una galleria di
ritratti che non abbiamo mai visto prima
e non c'è nessun altra testimonianza
simile di questa capacità sua su un
dipinto di creare così tante immagini
espressioni sentimenti movimento
tutto questo sta lì sotto
allora quando vediamo un dipinto forse
dovremmo chiederci ma è tutto quello che
c'è da vedere
e perché non proviamo allora a
domandarci a diventare un po più curiosi
a creare questo valore aggiunto che sta
in queste opere d'arte ma che per
qualche motivo come oggi la fruizione
delle nostre opere d'arte diciamo nella
migliora del delle dei modi è passiva
proviamo a renderla un po attiva
proviamo a vedere come tutto questo
potrebbe avvenire
e in questo caso
dettagli come questi non devono sembrare
magie della tecnologia io ho cercato
molto molto modestamente di sviluppare
insieme a dell'ingegneria degli
scienziati bravissima dei giovani
come arrivare a capire la creatività
come arrivare ad apprezzare la genesi di
un dipinto senza per questo essere
storici dell'arte e guardiamo se queste
in effetti oggi è possibile anche misura
e
vinci
scusate per l'inglese ma questo è
qualcosa che abbiamo sviluppato
all'università della california di san
diego insieme ad altre cose che più o
meno vi fanno capire che c'è un modo per
sapere di più vedere di più incuriosirci
ma più che altro farlo in maniera
diretta attiva interattiva e non essere
più così passivi quando andiamo in un
museo vediamo le opere d'arte leggiamo i
titoli ma degli autori delle opere ma
niente di più dov'è il messaggio che ci
arriva dobbiamo riscoprire tutto questo
e questo è uno dei tanti ruoli che la
scienza può avere ma non solo per le
opere d'arte in piazza della signoria e
prendiamo a caso un edificio e questo
edificio
scusa questo edificio per esempio è uno
dei palazzi che
stato costruito alla metà del
settecento che un edificio che può
sembrare
diciamo così non dico anonimo ma
certamente che non sembra rivelare altro
che quello che noi vediamo nel senso che
anche per gli edifici dei nostri centri
storici ma c'è una storia sono
evoluzione c'è una trasformazione
c'è in altre parole la nostra cultura
che bisogna riscoprire anche nei nostri
edifici storici e c'è modo di vedere
anche attraverso quello che può sembrare
il mondo del visibile anche sulle
strutture architettoniche
e questa volta usiamo un altra
tecnologia
sempre nel settore dell'infrarosso ma un
po più spinta
usiamo quello che si chiamano il flusso
termico e vediamo un immagine che di per
sé non ci sembra così altrettanto
significativa però se facciamo un po di
attenzione vediamo che c'è un andamento
diciamo obliquo quelle due linee lo
indicano come se ci ricordasse delle
falde di un tetto che vuol dire che vuol
dire molto di più di una curiosità vuol
dire che abbiamo riscoperto
quello che in piazza della signoria era
una chiesa costruita del mille poi
successivamente rifatta e ricostruita
nel xiv secolo cioè abbiamo riscoperto
un pezzo della nostra storia
dell'architettura abbiamo individuato
una chiesa che ritenevamo distrutta
pensate di poter fare questo nei nostri
centri storici edifici un suo edificio
ricostruire il nostro passato e anche
questo un modo per dare un futuro al
nostro passato e per sentirci parte di
questa scoperta di questa curiosità di
questa meraviglia
ma anche di questo si può rendere
noi stessi attivi nella scoperta nella
ricerca
permettetemi di introdurre un'altra
piccola diciamo un altro piccolo passo
usando una tecnologia che tutti oggi
stiamo utilizzando
ma per questo scopo e adesso
date un'occhiata a questo filmato
come vedete è un tablet si punta contro
la parete con le nostre mani sfreghiamo
sopra e si scopre quello che c'è sotto
l'intonaco si riscoprono porte si
riscoprono rifacimenti murari si
riscopre la storia di questa parete
da quando è stata edificata vale a dire
al
1497 anche questo immaginate di poter
andare ai nostri centri storici vedere
che facciate poter semplicemente con il
palmo della mano
cancellare quello che i nostri occhi
vedono e riscoprire il nostro passato lo
stesso propriamente si può fare nei
nostri musei si può andare con un tablet
cancellare quello che noi vediamo con i
nostri occhi e vedere la genesi
sottostante
ancora questa volta abbiamo parlato del
salone continuiamo accenniamo un po alla
battaglia di anghiari
sono lunga odissea questa battaglia che
comunque volgerà al termine più o meno
per la celebrazione di amerigo vespucci
del prossimo anno grazie fra l'altro
all'interesse la volontà del nostro
sindaco
e permettetemi anche di farvi vedere un
piccolo
una piccola visione breve molto breve
del salone acquisita con la modellazione
tridimensionale a mezzo centimetro che è
un contributo non è solo una curiosità
non solo per permettere a chiunque nel
mondo di poter vedere nostre bellezze ma
soprattutto anche come mezzo formidabile
di conservazione perché con questa
precisione l'altro le pitture murali
sono state documentate con l'istruzione
di un millimetro possiamo controllare
nel tempo l'evoluzione del degrado gli
eventuali spostamenti pensate solamente
a cosa non succede sul soffitto
e questo è una delle tante ricadute non
siamo nello spazio qui ma sono tante
tecnologie che poi ricadono sugli altri
beni culturali perché questo vuole
essere lo scopo ma vorrei far vedere
anche come siamo riusciti a ricostruire
com'era questo salone prima
dell'intervento del vasari che ha
cominciato all'incirca 1560 e come era
cioè la sala grande come vale a dire era
al tempo di non adatta vinci quando si è
accinto a dipingere la sua pittura
murale
come vedete era ben diverso soffitto
molto più basso c'erano delle finestre
che oggi non appaiono e soprattutto non
c'era questa ricchezza ma c'era leonardo
che ci ha lasciato comunque una
testimonianza incredibile tant'è vero
che però 360 anni questo capolavoro
considerato è chiamato la scuola del
mondo realtà manifestazione artistica ma
era giunta da nessuno e leonardo era
stato incaricato di fare questa pittura
come il pittore e celso a firenze quando
allora c'erano persone come michelangelo
raffaello botticelli ghirlandaio
verrocchio e così via vi faccio vedere
come a che punto siamo adesso
su queste pareti perché su questa che
abbiamo identificato il luogo dove è
stata dipinta la pittura
cancellate per un momento immaginate di
poter rimuovere tutta la pittura di
rimuovere tutto l'intonaco e si legge
ogni pietra ogni mattone per capire cosa
è successo
quali sono le trasformazioni dove
dobbiamo andare a cercare perché è fra
l'altro insieme ad una ricerca
documentaria poi siamo ci siamo
concentrati sull'ultimo dei pannelli di
destra di questa parete est e in effetti
poi abbiamo anche trovato un
intercapedine tramite un'indagine radar
fatta in collaborazione anche con
l'università di firenze con una società
di pisa che ci ha permesso di capire che
in effetti in quella zona è lì dove
leonardo ci ha lasciato la sua battaglia
d'anghiari ed è quella che andremo a
scoprire
fra poco ed è più o meno questo che ci
aspettiamo
se non così di trovare ma certamente
nella zona questo è senz'altro il
anche dimensionalmente quanto ci
aspettiamo di trovare
quindi abbiamo fatto un'escursione
rapidissimo vedo che manca poco è il
momento di più che altro di indicare
alcune proposte che fra le tantissime
che potremmo attivare anche oggi
la fruizione interattiva avete visto
pochissimi esempi ma quanto ci sarebbe
da sviluppare sia in ambienti museali
che anche sul territorio cioè
quest'argomento reality chiaramente
vanno sviluppati ma va sviluppato anche
contenuti e questo si fanno con campagna
di indagini scientifiche su tantissimi
dei nostri capolavori riscopriamo i
nostri capolavori e usiamo la scienza
per farlo usiamo la passione e tanti
giovani sviluppo di tecnologie per la
diagnostica
per il restauro e il monitoraggio dei
nostri beni culturali
ci sono tantissime tecnologie che
potremmo prendere modificare reinventare
che già esistono partendo da le
tecnologie spaziali la creazione di una
cartella clinica digitale sembra ovvio
ma non è mai stato fatto i nostri beni
culturali hanno bisogno di essere
trattati come pazienti ma abbiamo
bisogno di qualcuno che allora le tratti
come pazienti ci abbiamo bisogno della
figura del medico che non esiste abbiamo
il restauratore avevano storico
dell'arte dove lo scienziato
conservatore dobbiamo crearla questa
figura e ci sono migliaia di ragazzi già
laureati che hanno bisogno di avere il
loro titolo di studio riconosciuto come
conservatori per potere entrare e poter
dare il loro contributo per salvare e
valorizzare i nostri beni culturali
e anche dargli delle funzioni e dei
ruoli tutto questo costa zero
allo stato e ancora non è stato fatto
e poi il monitoraggio stesso dei beni
culturali non possiamo preoccuparci
sempre solo della nostra salute e
questo questo insieme immenso di di beni
culturali che abbiamo lasciarla andare
come se fosse qualcosa di
impossibile da gestire o se come se
tanto abbiamo tante cose
una più una meno
non ci rendiamo conto che questo è il
nostro vero bene nostro vero futuro
e la ricerca non invasiva presenza di
siti archeologici
oggi sono le tecnologie per fare una
mappatura sistematica di tutti i nostri
beni archeologici e sono enormi ancora
non scoperte ma anche sott'acqua perché
dobbiamo aspettare che ce le rubinho e
non fare noi essere i primi noi a
rendersi conto di quanto tutto questo è
importante per la nostra per la nostra
cultura ma anche perché è un nostro bene
e allora il mondo a maggior ragione
viene a trovarci ad aiutarci a portarci
soldi ma soprattutto a dare possibilità
a noi di creare tanti indotti su tutto
questo
così come anche tecnologia dei nostri
uffici esportazioni che non si capisce
perché quante opere d'arte ci vengano
rubate ma anche esportate illegalmente o
semplicemente anche tramite canali
illegali e manco lo sappiamo
c'è tutto questo depauperamento di opere
d'arte
dobbiamo riscoprire cioè dare un futuro
per il passato di vuol dire anche
stimolare proprio questa curiosità
questa meraviglia la ricerca in altre
parole di una nostra identità culturale
che passa anche attraverso questa
riscoperta qui proprio qui si parlava di
di uomo universale
cioè quel concetto di
rinascimento dell'uomo stesso
che però oggi noi si deve riscoprire di
nuovo con una cultura veramente
interdisciplinare perché i nostri
giovani hanno bisogno della cultura
interdisciplinare
io personalmente non credo che la strada
sia sempre di più nella
superspecializzazione quanto di un
allargamento di conoscenza e di cultura
che servirà ai nostri giovani per
affrontare proprio le sfide di un mondo
così eterogenea così complesso grazie
grazie